heures et haute tension à montpellier
pour l'acte 64 du mouvement des
centaines de manifestants se sont
retrouvés dans la matinée place de la
comédie
le rassemblement s'est d'abord déroulée
dans le calme avant que la situation
prennent une autre tournure en début
d'après-midi canons à eau gaz
lacrymogènes grenades de désencerclement
et sommation pour disperser la foule
les forces de l'ordre ont essayé non
sans mal de ramener le calme dans les
rues de montpellier mais ils ont eu
beaucoup de difficultés face à la
détermination des gilet jaune à paris
malgré l'interdiction par la préfecture
du parcours demandé par les gilet jaune
des manifestants se sont tout de même
réuni vers 13 heures devant le conseil
d'état
alors que des gilet jaune était menacée
par les forces de l'ordre
d'autres manifestants à leur tour
encerclé le cortège policier les
manifestants s'étaient ensuite donné
rendez vous à l'école militaire afin de
poursuivre la mobilisation
la situation s'est tendue avec
l'interpellation de jérôme rodrigues
l'une des figures du mouvement ce qui a
provoqué la colère de nombreux gilet
jaune mais aussi du principal intéressé
aujourd'hui que macro motors je dis
merde à monsieur l'allemand les mecs me
court après pour m'arrêter en disant
monsieur rodriguez s'il vous plaît
contrôle d'identité ils savent qui je
suis
ils savent qui je suis ils viennent me
contrôler soit disant que cette rue là
là avenue de tourville la lui m'ont
arrêté et dans un truc interdite ce
n'est nullement stipulé dans l'arrêté
ils ont mis une amende à un endroit où
j'ai le droit de me balader tout
simplement donc aujourd'hui monsieur
l'allemange vous regarde droit dans les
yeux je vous dis merde vous allez
détruit ma vie
vous avez détruit ma vue vous avez ruiné
ma vie
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez me
mettre en prison je suis un [ __ ] de
pause en politique et je vais vous
emmerdez toute votre vie et je veux le
dire mon temps et je vous le dis vous
serez jamais accompagné tout le temps de
300 policiers et un jour ou l'autre vous
aurez en face de moi et vous croiserez
le regard que vous avez mutilés c'est
tout à la suite de cette interpellation
jérôme rodrigues a écopé d'une amende de
135 euros
comme lui plus de 400 manifestants ont
été verbalisés dans des zones interdites
à la manifestation ce samedi dans la
capitale
[Musique]